The pandemic was a death knell for many brands.
Eight thousand seven hundred stores were closed by big chain retailers in America in 2020,...
...but the companies that did harness the power of their consumers' data are thriving.
Amazon exceeded 100 billion dollars in quarterly sales...
...for the first time ever in the last three months of 2020.
Amazon, of course, wrote the book on individual customer data and its uses,...
...and of course, as they got bigger and bigger and bigger,...
...they've got more data than anybody else.
With its established logistical system and smooth purchasing process,...
...Amazon may seem a useful online platform for brands to peddle their wares.
But though Amazon passes on the sale to the brand,...
...it doesn't pass on much of the customers' data,...
...which means companies know very little about who is buying their products.